we are here at the playing venue with
Berta who is a chess fan and came here
Berta welcome to the show tell us a bit
about your chess experience
so last year was a very nice very
attention when you see the players there
playing all the time and we see you in
the same time many games is very
interesting also but tension or
sometimes you keep with one of the
players and not yours will be the winner
he's very nice in the well very well
organized when did you start playing
chess and what is your average level
let's see my level is 900 and some on
chess.com but I'm playing every day I'm
trying to get a better better
performance but I don't know how it be
in the future I'm also registrated to a
chess club
but I'm trying what attracts you to
chess is it the social aspect going to
the club and playing with other people
what is it yeah what you mentioned it's
been interesting to play with colleagues
to try to catch some technique to have a
plus plus value
this is my
your interesting chess and tell us a bit
about this particular tournament who is
your favorite player
well in reality my favorite place
player is Magnus
from here is Nepal Nepal yeah well that
was a heartbreak a couple of weeks ago
because he lost the guest thing I was
almost cry after the game this is it God
willing yes also well Berta it's a
pleasure to see you here it's a pleasure
to see the environment here
um with these amazing players at the
Superbad chess classic thank you very
much for taking the time thank you
[Music]
thank you